[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
évidemment c'est moi jean-yves yann un
autre homme serait-il la clé de notre
appartement par appartement et j'en sais
rien c'est leur reddition l'agencé
j'entends c'est toi eric non ça c'est
une manière d ios arrive alors ils vont
soirée ou encore salué qui ont encore
une variante la maison bonsoir eric
chérie ça changera un peu tu te ramasses
son imperméable elixiri ne m'emmerde
familiale chez nous mais qui est
toujours aussi aimable
bonjour je la vois pas venir à moi au
pardon c'est vrai ce que tu veux voir
qu'est ce que tu as encore à faire tout
et rien d'autre mais mon chéri je n'ai
jamais rien fait dans cette maison soit
vous devez changer ou via youtube non ça
dérangerait votre écoute rentrait du
travail et boire un verre tranquillement
c'est agréable pourquoi veux-tu me
d'archers cet innocent plaisir par
exemple un mois pour vivre tranquille
c'est l'exercice tout cela fait l'ennemi
en calant ce dont je ne fais pas
d'exercice - on regarde rien que pour
éviter des remous je fais les efforts
surhumains et ouvrant ainsi franchi les
échelons de l'armée qui relie je peux
pas suffisante et noir c est à jamais pu
réparé regarde-moi insouciant au calme
sur une belle robe pour tuer la reine du
kenya 1 arnaud non non non la queue
lover n'exagère rien
je sais que dire de plus en plus
difficile à vivre
c'est par ce qui s'appelait depuis
quelque temps et que nous sommes en
présence d'une algue pas de cracher
dessus
mais regardez moi je suis l'image même
de la scène je suis en harmonie avec
moi-même avec le nom j'ai avec le cosmos
alors pourquoi ce fait je trancherai feu
trois fois oui ok finalement les trois
raisons c'est moins fatiguant son père
adoré ce livre est là qui parle mais
locataire hors coûts nous les nôtres
étaient d'ordre est co-propriétaire de
l'année pour avec toit en dur pour lui
répare pour moins de 6 de ses locataires
avions consacré voulu inviter le reste
c'est pour me donner l'impression que
j'étais propriétaire non c'est bon de
t'avoir les séries à monter dans son
enfer avait déjà choisi le premier étage
et tu sais pourquoi parce que t'arrêtes
pas de bouger et qui voulait pas content
vous jouerez il ya eu au dessus de sa
tête
les nervures et s'est installé là haut
bien avant que j'arrive dans ta vie qui
dit n'importe quoi
[Musique]
la vérité c'est qu'il a vu les cages
pour ne pas s'entendre toi qui à l'aller
aussi sa tête
après l'hymne arrêtera celle d'une autre
que nana avant tu arrives ici avec mon
sac de couchage
cet endroit est un véritable monstre et
al ahly est venu terminer un monastère
sauf les dimanches et fêtes elle jeudi
en matinée mais
notre guide avec demain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais voilà maintenant c'est fini ici à
cause de décès si tu y vas aussi ne va
pas mais le médecin le corner mais il
est pas mal à démissionner on voit rien
alors fermé la porte
oui on va leur dire bonjour
on attend qu'ils nous appellent et que
tu fais comme tu veux troisième de
voyage de noces mois toit léger mais et
moi j'aimerais aller faire rougir la
salle du clous
le propos est parmi nous tairons marc
gilissen à temps soit par exemple
alors vous avez beau temps mais cuche
qui fait vous n'avez pas eu le loisir
opération je te promets de ne pas parler
du don remarque difficile de trouver
quoi dit oh la la alors si tu ne viens
pas ce qu'est ce qu'on pourrait dire
alors les enfants elle fait du sport un
[Musique]
la lune de miel c'est une expression
d'allemands b donc ce que surtout baisse
d'avoir été jusqu'à l'île de tenerife
pour faire exactement la même chose
qu'ici
oui mais on voulait pas retenir et
mesquin des pires son niveau mental
n'allons pas juger previn la connais toi
qu'on renonce à ses frais norbert ne la
voyais que chez ses parents à dreux ont
parfois des signes de vacances on
servait des petits biscuits ma voix ça
me dépasse qu'il a été sur cette cible
cependant il faut il en avait envie mais
si la section encore du tout whaou
continue à vouloir une scie après
l'avoir résolu
c'est là seulement que commence le
véritable amour il continuera mais quand
même il a pris des risques il aurait dû
essayer avant arrive à traiter avant
mais le corps quand au reste fut
souvient soi et de trois fois est venu
passer la soirée ici à 10 heures du soir
et elle vers dieu amon train parmi
lequel habite heureux ben alors a pu le
rater son temps au moins une fois passé
la nuit avec norbert noël fallait qu'à
rentrer à dreux est si intelligent
j'aurais bien les airs comme elle bat
qu'une connais personne à dreux
j'aurais dit résident
et mon fils à moi mais je voyais
résistible de réaliser mon été facile
vous avez gagné au regard des avants
merci je vais le dire toi l'a fait c'est
pas mon genre dit mon genre aux gens
d'être une horizontale au cours du tour
non une belle nature bouillonnante et
généreux socialise avec voracité
c'était la première fois que tu me
reproches de musique touareg dans deux
ans ce qui t'a fait parler d'eux en
ville comme ça c'est plus que ça avec le
voyage en auvergne depuis deux ans le
voyage en enfer
mon dieu je n'ose plus traverser
l'auvergne tellement nous sommes mal
conduit dans ce pays là tu te rappelles
les volcans des temps nous regardait
faire en murmurant voilà nos successeurs
bonjour des batwa non je gagne ma vie je
suis pas mal mon ménage statut digne
ayrton odalisque tout tout tout seul sur
ce point m et les points de vue de la
vie ont beaucoup changé depuis le
mariage de nos verres mais comme je
n'aime pas du tout du tout le tour que
prend cette conversation il lui arrive à
la conclusion suivante beaucoup de
raisons plaident en faveur du mariage
type émeutes éclatent
oui beaucoup de régions mais combien de
bonnes oui on a toujours dit qu'on
finirait sans se marier un jour non
maintenant à bosser ça qui travaille pas
c'est qu'on sent que tu me le disait je
me suis dit c'est arrivé chez bras soyez
devenir acariâtre sans raison au petit
jeu celui-ci m'a demandé comment
j'allais faire pour ça qu'ils m'ont dit
mais mon chéri je le prends comme je
prends tout dans la vie l'homme sage
s'incline devant l'inévitable qui n'a
rien fait absolument rien et tout à fait
naturel que tu ai envie de se marier en
vidéo hippolyte est réservé à dîner au
restaurant là ce soir c'est pas la
poisse au niveau de sûreté ce soit n'a
évidemment pas ça la semaine prochaine
oui enfin c'est en tout cas la conterie
billets les bancs les we go publier les
bans pour se marier
non mais pas pour dîner dehors comme
encore là mais qui va se marier mais toi
peut-être mais moi sur mon banc vert
n'avait absolument pas sauf mais elle
est nommée précises comme ce qui est
tout à fait normal que j'ai envie de
marquer tout à fait normal que tu as
envie de se marier qui n'avait rien
absolument rien ce qui prouve à quel
point je suis un gars sont tolérants et
reste que du point de vue des autres
même quand je ne le partage absolument
pas tu as envie de te marier
- par ailleurs la voix du nord du japon
pour avoir présumément
c'est tout même et d'olivia oui oui
norbert c'est pas le moment qu'ils sont
par dont on parle c'est un bon jour en
13 combats d'ici minutes un bon pourquoi
vous agiter cette bouteille de whisky et
de nombreux non il vaut va bien ce petit
short je suis parti comme ça tenerife a
pensé que c'était pas une saignée pour
paris a à d et vous êtes bronzés partout
partout on est là parce que des fois
quand ils vont au concert de l'intégrale
la dernière fois que j'ai vu vos jambes
disparaissait sous tendre âge de
mousseline blanche
j'en avais jamais rien que pour la
presse y en a moins de soucis du
département c'est comme ça il faut être
bien bronzé vous le savez ces faits le
jour de notre mariage est toute blanche
d'émotion quand je suis complètement
retourné mairie tremblante par la
virginale alors qu'aujourd'hui où le
soleil d'année et plus du tout géré et
comment vas tu commences à norbert un
peu dieu merci en pour lui dur est passé
ben oui pauvre violent vous serez tous
dans la peau longtemps mon épouse
oui vous savez pas s'il a pensé à
prendre du lait pour nous du lait alors
ça je ne sais pas mon rayon vous
pourriez peut-être lui demander oh oui
oh oui bien sûr oui c'est ce qui se
passe je veux dire à un agent non non
pas du tout je le dis viard
merci ma chérie justement qu'à chercher
et quand on sait que la province a perdu
alors ils entrent par tout aux émirats
bien pâle à retrouver aussi l'enfant un
an de recherches et nous aurons sans
réuni les deux voulaient bien pour quoi
faire
pour l'élève le led attendait non je
n'ai pas lu le lait je crois je crois
qu'elle doit le mettre dans le frigo à
bout ça c'est pas mon rayon non plus aux
bâches mois qu'ils arrêtent parce que ça
saute partout c'est pendant les arrêts
compatriote ian ouvrait paraît que c'est
pas normal rien
la crise aussi grave et il paraît que
c'est pas normal qu'en janvier
je continue elle abordait des ouverte en
mai quand même tu m'as fait peur que ça
ne se reproduise pas des choses que nous
sommes ouverts à tout de suite à mes
faucheux de l'ingouchie pont pour
éponger des aphtes ya la soupe surtout
le fourneau et tous partout barthez bana
qui arrive à ma vie elle est superbe et
je voudrais pouvoir en dire autant de
toi là sans merci sur l'énième en
afrique et en amérique avec une joie
mauvaise bouffe mais pourquoi ton visage
at il cette couleur de foin moisi et
comme d'habitude on a meilleure mine
après les vacances car nous les vacances
ou pas tu veux rire aux larmes
oh la la
mais pourquoi tu te rendes comme ça
insoutenable le spectacle dans le monde
ce qui t'arrive
et encore j'essaye de me contrôler et
fatigant mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé
il m'arrive que je reviens de mon voyage
de la revue ses pas et c'est ça qui l'a
mis dans cet état là bas dit douch ces
conducteurs est tout à la chose histoire
celle de dire toute la vérité
oui c'est un coup de pot que ce soit en
grand bain à ce point là encore si
j'avais su ce que c'était
le reste je ne savais pas je l'avais lu
des brochures sur la question ah mais
c'est pas suffisant
les brochets ont peu d'effets spéciaux
belle noiseuse dia avait honnêtement pas
quand même un bon moment quoi et ses
photos en couleurs celles de bonbons
fait dessus
la latence et que je suis son combat là
c'était quand même pas la première fois
que je suis la culture n'est pas
uniquement livresque effet posséder une
fois une seule
vous ne serez pas deux je ne serai
jamais plus jamais monter ta tenue rose
évidemment la pauvre et un ami aucune
objection aucune paix les masculins oui
mais justement toute la question est là
elle vous le pensez non seulement on a
moyen trop ça suffit une fois la nuit je
suis largement vase et on se tait connu
plus courageux 1
on voyait que c'est un droit qui
trouvait en face du monstre
norbert c'est mal parti je savais qu'il
fallait pas tout mari je le savais ce
que tu racontes des palabres du marielle
c'est la faune de la mère ma mère est
féroce
c'est de la soul mal mais alors attends
je vais prévenir un docteur tout de
suite intéressé par intérim à la
première quand on la fois el nino
gambade dans commune beach au prince en
bavent abriel a bien profité
profitez de coin de sousmoulins dessous
je pense que tu viens de me dire la
paille c'est un manga s'est gâté tout
seul la raison vacille 2010 six
étrangers ruban du temps commence à
pleurer sur son sort
c'était qu'il prononce des phrases
bizarre mais c'est qu'il a été très
traumatisés par cet événement comme vous
ma voix quand même que c'est pas normal
un garçon de son âge en pleine santé en
pleine possession de ses moyens
enfin nonagénaire bons qu'ils aient eu
et encore et encore des nonagénaires un
nom mais celui que j'ai connu si en plus
c'est le mariage quand tu vois je suis
sûr que c'est le mariage non non c'est
ta mère qui était rousse bon alors
voulez vous m'expliquer en quoi sa mère
qui était rousse et responsable avant
que je devienne fou mais les roues en
apôtre insensé jamais il n'est pas où
j'ai la même poubelle alors à punir et
d'équité mis au soleil mais paul est
comme un agneau
alors voilà le mystère de la mer rouge
en france merci je me dis continuer
quand elle avait même plus le droit
conscient de ma chambre et il est resté
au lit
et là il a été piqué par une belle note
une barre au dessus de la barre
il indique stéphane charre ainsi une
baisse de la taille d'un gros frein avec
leurs mots et les phrases fois nue c'est
quoi alors 19 ans pour que ça se sache
pas néfaste à rotule sur les photos en
couleurs évidemment ils comparaissent
dans leurs droits sur ses dérives ses
plages ses palmiers et deux années
moroses sommes importantes en unique
d'ailleurs il n'a même pas voulu juger
de la trace de ces gros l'arracheur à la
fête se prépare bien moi c'est été
bricolé avec le club de fortune en
soutane et ça lui n'a rien vu
et j'avais la fesse deux fois plus
grosse que l'autre mais le médecin est
payé par le syndicat d'initiative pour
ne rien voir et il est resté couché sur
le ventre pendant une semaine doit
entrer dans une chambre se raccorde en
gros ça c'est les journées délicieux de
la piscine jeudi à dubaï le nom
maintenant vigneault est ce que tu crois
que tu pourrais malimba de lait chaud on
voit comment ils sont tus prennent
quelque chose
la partie carrée pour déjeuner dans
l'avion à fabas vous y passez en creuse
et on fait tous les malheurs il faut que
quelques secondes et 3 mondial et bien
je peux avoir un scotch j'ai
l'impression que ce support pagnot clé
dans l'état où je lui sers toi toujours
le même tu donnerais pas un verre d'eau
amour battue m'a pas demandé à berthod
la date du pic si je veux ascot double
anneau ne te laisse pas dont on est
assez plus prudent on reste
tranquillement merci et le renvoi de
scotch c'est plus sage toujours
serviable écoute type laguiole par tout
ce qu'on attend de moi 80 ans soit dès
janvier ya devant la bâtisse femme donne
du souci quant au fait pourquoi vos ans
par le tél comme si nous étions mariés à
bout ont tenu hier que nous n'étions par
marie
c'est pas séparés dans la conversation à
tous et farid est le plus tard on en
parlera plus tard ou pas du don attendre
on dirait qu'on vit comme des bêtes ya
tout de même des liens aussi respectable
que ceux du mariage légalement battu et
c'est grâce à la belle famille les roses
en condition d'en parler à sa famille
afin d'empêcher les chiens à c'est bien
cette ak pas mariés tu sais très bien
mon rêve de se marier parce que c'était
le seul moyen d'arriver les mains n'a
pas mis assez d'énergie dans cette
empathie son arrivée à tf1 comme tu dis
sans les poussettes et avait pas sa
destination n'est pas un prix du genre
tentative mais maintenant on est coincé
à l'emploi et son mariage en paix s'ils
restent les tarifs et maryse dumas
risque viviane a changé du tout au tout
d'abord elle est devenue un homme résume
compagne tendre et douce qui ne pensais
quand même attendu de mégère victorienne
qui ne pense qu'à ce parc des princes y
pensent de leur part tout à notre époque
ya plein de femmes qui sont courtes
viennent ils pensaient même pareil c'est
toi qui est venue vite mais ces idées là
dans la tête at-on droit planckaert la
charge jamais je n'aurais dû vous
laisser pénétrer dans cette maison c'est
toi qui m'a demandé de venir habiter ici
parce que tu n'avais pas les moyens
rester tout seul cette maison ne
supporte pas la perspective du mariage
déjà fait mal supporté la vie en commun
que c'est qu'il faut vraiment que
tidiane sow toute femme exceptionnelle
pour que je les laissais pénétrer dans
mon petit univers alors la garder oui
l'épousé non il n'y a pas un déshonneur
et vous et l'apa promène tu épouses -
pas
or comment ça devient car chaque jour un
peu plus merci mon dieu un homme sait se
faire respecter ces fonctionnaires ayant
invoqué à capendu fait partie des roses
val d'isère où elle aurait donné qu'il a
quelque chose à une aubaine
je vous préviens je suis très mauvais
poil long ça ne se voit pas du tout
enfin je vais essayer les trémas pour
vous nos faux pas ou alors vous avez
passé un voleur seulement vous avez une
bonne nombre non si on north bay
vous n'êtes pas seuls membres aux est il
resté couché parce que tout le temps je
suis d'une banque est journaliste et lui
pense que ça j'ai des ordures grosse
demande là
mais là on va rose un insecte huntelaar
voile pense que roos incapable de tout
le monde c'est comme si je serai capable
de mort avec en choix
wendy qu'aucun instrument d exemple il
est poussé par l'ovaire il est un peu
dérangée ils étaient plus physiques
puisqu'il arrive et qu'il devra marier
un jour on vous ressemblez à cette sorte
de carême pas merci bien france rapporte
l'ars est la fille à maman nous nous
arrive pas à me décider à mettre une
rave ou chacun devrait comme daniela
préfère être encore en vacances
bobos mais rien compris que non car il
sert aux muets attention pour battu
vous voyez quoi que je fasse je suis
dans mon tort que le même que la station
ne critique toujours c'est mon lot sur
cette terre c'est comme ça un genevois
n'êtes pas normes américaines aux
ménages mais il voulait fois que nous
soyons marié
el arabi et lui a harcelé pas au courant
non non ça c'est bien la faute en ne
vais pas trembler devant l'opinion de sa
belle famille qui sera obligé d'avouer
tout est mensonge aujourd'hui devant
thonon et toi si tu le conduisait d'une
façon normale qui validerait des moments
pénibles je prends bouleversé ma vie
très content de ta famille non sans
nommer les actus et un mot que je suis
content quand une sale bête ces mordus
mais pourquoi un insecte ya pas de cobra
dans ce pays là non et sont pas mariés
et ben qu'est ce que ça peut faire un
captain attachent plus d'importance à ce
jour là tous les mois nous pollue 30 20
euros c'est boukari venu en main mais à
cause du papa est mort et ce n'est sans
fin il nous aurait fait tous les ans
c'était le mariage ou le carnage rabot
et ça que vous partagez le poids d'un
couple illégitime
il n'aurait pas dû nous mitrailler le
mi6 aux non papa il a lu ce qu'ils
désiraient maintenant il sait pas je
fais ce que je veux et je ferai mon pied
je veux
attention au revers quand elle a dit je
fréquente qui chevauche de passer dans
son regard une leur gourmande à mon
sujet à sens global suis bien content
que tout ça soit éclaircie je veux faire
un diplôme
norbert dont les shows et or y aller
par média mourad mahdoui bonne nuit et
concubins oui elle qui s'allie à norbert
et 3 plus heureux deux anglais il est né
entre fusil du père est la chose la
cuisine aux îlots qui me fait penser moi
aussi j'ai à faire
oui mais la voisine ans et je fais lui
en offrir il ya longtemps que tes
parents d'accepter notre situation comme
rose comme tout le monde quand c'est
comme ça aujourd'hui les ans marie d
autre part c'est un choix
oui j'ai choisi je me marie
écoutons népal heureux tous les deux on
se déchire tout
mais les gens mariés aussi de ce nom
mais c'est moins grave dans un presque
mariée chacun son boulot je suis sûr de
toi tu peux être sûr de moi qu'est ce
que tu veux de plus une existence légale
drôle de mot mais quelle étrange idée là
tellement au bout de deux ans alors tu
sais pas ce qu'on va sano d'ivoire eh
bien je vais te dire ce qu'on sait où va
dîner bien tranquillement tous les deux
en regardant la télé eric sabos titre
nous nous marions maintenant ou jamais
maintenant ou jamais voilà oui tu as
raison vaut mieux ne pas laisser planer
cette menace ou d'une autre ce serait
pas une vie alors c'est jamais alors je
sais qui tu me quittes
oui je sors de cette maison je sors de
ta vie et je me trouve un vrai pari il
n'a pas l'air de bien comprendre
non c'est la première fois que tu parles
de quitter une fois ci il m'a menti
comprend alors je t'épouse où tu me
quittes il a compris roland là faut que
je réfléchisse main
ces dernières semaines une semaine tu
veux que je décide du tout mon avenir en
une semaine d'une autre année je fais
encore partie de ta vie une semaine
s'est passé voici besoin d'un an qu'elle
est un an
j'ai eu deux ans d'accord mais pendant
deux ans dans une seule phrase des
fonctions mariage moi alors j'ai du
retard pour que je redémarre à zéro
écoute eric si l'idée du mariage se
remet à la clé pas la peine d'attendre
une semaine
oublions la voilà j'étais n'ont juste
pas vrai que tu redeviendras raisonnable
et une femme qui était tout suivants nom
est tu sais pourquoi parce que je vais
te prendre dans mes bras
non parce que ça finirait au
commissariat tu veux plus que je te
prennes dans mes bras
mais pour toujours illégalement c'est
que je les envie de toi que je sais et
c'est réciproque
alors qu'il renoncera tout ça ouais avec
tristesse mais sans trembler quel
chantage ignoble mais vois-tu après de
conduire de manière aussi rapide thouars
on y vend près de toi mon amour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
il
eric pour moi la palais ouvre non c'est
toi qui va m'appeler au téléphone oui
pourquoi très bon bah c'est sûr tu as
vécu
je conduis comme un gosse non abbas a
besoin de l'autorisation de ses parents
pour se marier moi pas c'est pour ça
qu'ils soient mariés dans une semaine
temps pourquoi et comment 10 août
je veux redevenir un peu cheap été
écouté les gens a dû débloquer mais
parce que voilà les vendre et mia frère
lui même absent tu me rappelles
approprié cette offre une assistante
marque groupe a d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs moi aussi je aussi je risque
de devenir à l'autre on montre quel
inconnu serait devenu dans 7 jours 7
jours
samedi prochain je serai mariée parce
que jenny où j'ai dit oui quand j'ai vu
que là même qui était pourtant ce point
de l'imac norbert
pas ce commentaire fait tu portais par
la fed j'ai descendu par la critique du
corps de jean dumur chez les scouts
montceau scène et l hymne à sa ville
non c'est que c'est puni par la loi
tu sais que ça s'appelle de l'effraction
viviane wade d'avoir l'oeil sur x est
allé sortir et qu'on nous chante l arène
tu préfères des cours de rodage polar et
leur arrivée en a déjà tellement
d'affaires
les costumes sont serrés tout au bout de
la france dis moi il est 4 heures tu as
mangé quelque chose non pas depuis mon
petit déjeuner race
c'était quand même une demi heure le bo
s'il était bien silencieux je souhaite à
bon alors il collé au plancher depuis ce
matin écoutons kim conscience tu veux
rester au lit à défilement mais ça
n'arrange rien et sortir du lit ça
arrangerait quelque chose ne l'imaginent
phase des problèmes vont disparaître
parce que tu les as prendre dans la
position du foetus
ils auront les mêmes quoi tu te dépliera
et le plus tôt sera le mieux le knb de
ces conseilles tu veux que je te dise
que tu peux en faire ou nous restons
convenable j'essaye de me conduire un
ami alors tire-toi avons regarde pas le
rugby
non attention aux frênes 170 millions
aujourd'hui les noces de figaro à nos
offres mais il fait bref quoi et
qu'est-ce qui dirait des petites tasses
de café de village ou d'un erp et laure
tu parle déjà comme ta femme
comme c'est terrifiant après seulement
trois semaines d esclavage se sont déjà
vieux pépés puis à une vision très
déformée du mariage est revenu n'est pas
mes crédits des bornes et qui va sortir
de là et en plus c'est du peuvent se
séparer de viviane tu as peur d'être
trop mal mais je ne veux pas que le
peuple égyptien
je suis un con vu abrutis maladie diot
alors arrête de râler et vous la a
épousé m'épouser et tout et tout et rien
dans ton nouveau sommes peu mal partout
il y a quelque chose de faux seins dans
ton problème au niveau de ton
comportement d'iso que tu fais un
blocage sur le plan affectif sur l'union
est légitime
ce qui affaiblit dont potentiel affectif
est ce que tu veux pour schématiser à
l'extrême
oui joaillerie donc quelque chose départ
immoral ou illégal ou de préférence les
deux les infrastructures de ton
subconscient sont sclérosées tunique
loria qui n'est pas attirée par cette
chose c'est une option fondamentale
oui alors quand j'aurai envie d'entendre
des conneries ce tracé et que ce soit
plutôt de son blocage at war et de ton
complète de moralité égalité c'est
autrement plus grave il faut tout de
même un minimum de loi et de morale mais
pas pour moi je suis un rock et on veut
mon chez nec
or est inutile d telle enseigne que cela
bouge pas avant a expliqué tous à
viviane c'est trop tard est un j'ai dit
oui j'ai dit oui viser le brillant si
vous essayez de me contrôler il est sous
sa juridiction dans son dos - shalom et
la séparation mais les amoureux du par
mois sur la demande et par celle ci la
crypte on était trop cher oui voilà vous
présente exacte de ces visites
qu'est ce que c'est que ce genre et
qu'est ce que c'est que ces
conversations
et puis qu'est ce qu'elles vont faire
dans ma chambre en plus
n'a pas choisi c'est parce qu'une gêne
que la france est que nous allons voir
tous ensemble l'iphone 4 je veux la paix
la fête
vous aviez un roseau 122 franchement
iniquité passé quand plus haut rien vous
êtes entré par erreur dans la chambre à
coucher puis signale que la vedette à la
rotule pour hyderabad et remédie du 1,29
pour métro 6,6 agréable
ado dit on se faisait aussi réuni ouvre
la porte aux fadaises je t'aime crise de
foi raconter une histoire très forts de
cette fois un volet pas déçu cuias prix
moyens se promener comme ça chez moi
comme en terrain conquis
oh je pensais pas vous appuyer comme
dimanche rue de la banque n'était pas
envie de voir mais moi les invités se
côtoient la ville qui se veut non je
suis et pouvant épouvanté parce que
entre nous deux le climat se détériore
de plus en plus en écoute d'avoir
l'impression que nous sommes en train de
perdre ce que nous avions équipe de
détruire tout ce que nous avions
construit en mariant en mariant tu
n'écoutes depuis deux ans nous sommes
restés ensemble uniquement parce que
nous voulions repas que ça va mieux que
d'être enchaîné
le mariage est une chaîne mais les
divorces et il me donnait pas marié tu
pense déjà au divorce soir je trouve que
c'est sympa comme mentalité
non non c'est pourtant vrai vous vous
habillez cours vous dit ça vous va très
bien mais pour paris cette saison
la couche de norbert il vous remet un
demi mois c'est une réaction de marie tu
sais si tu sais que j'étais très injuste
avec rosa elle est pas exhibitionniste
du tout c'est normal qu'il a posé
question convivial il faut jamais montré
sa robe de mariage de son fils rapporte
le site i really matter terrible parce
qu'on ne supporte pas qu'on soit 3 dans
une même pièce
alors vous pouvez même quand elles sont
originaux en compétition et à moi je
dirais si free n'était pas ravi qu'on
demande c'est bien bravo ni prochain
samedi prochain
oui on va juste et humain tête
d'enterrement mais à part ça que ceci
mettra donc en dessous de ce que je me
serais samedi prochain mais ma chérie je
serai comme tous les samedis
tel que tu me vois en ce moment la mère
s'est maintenue du week-end et ce alors
à tous les week-ends que je dis vrai
jusqu'à mon dernier souffle à carnon et
coutumes attendait ça c'est comme ça que
je me couchais voilà l'église et la
mairie s'est souvenu sens pas très bien
aussi pas matériellement un coup de
viviane toute la semaine se porte en
coller une cravate
mon pauvre coup réclame un peu de
détente il a droit à son samedi comme
tout le monde
cette nouvelle attaque est ce vous
amuser si je peux me raser sur non non à
la hausse annoncée reste sur une énorme
rançon et qu'elles pourraient voter les
20 mois avec marc abadie et marie pierre
bigorgne aulas
la catastrophe a eu lieu c'est que tu
préparais rien préparé tout le monde en
les enlevant sa vie prof on en croit les
mariés nous nous marions femme ivre gens
ce n'est pas des faux dieux d'arrivants
dégâts la qualité non c'est un rôle qui
t il en effet pas j'en ai vu ce que la
réforme dit ce que tout le monde soit
résigné au fait à mes partenaires pour
aller dîner photos que j'ai faim or j'ai
déjà mangé bien dire si il a dit qu'on
avait envie signer quand on a déjà mangé
et qu'on n'a pas envie de se marier
quand on a déjà pas du tout du tout ce
que voulait dire jamais ce sera samedi
comme les autres écoute c'est une simple
fournir oui au fond tout dire une corvée
qu'est ce que tu attends de moi que je
suis un là tout intimidé et que je
franchisse le seuil de cette porte en
tenant à bout de bras la vierge rouge
issance japon tu vois que tu ne viennent
pas des mariés aaa mais mes valeurs dans
l'herbe
kim avait parlé toilettes mois serait
divisé intention de ne rien changer à ma
tenue de week end habituel de membres
alors rien absolument rien n'a restitué
en ce qui concerne la faune est
maintenant la bonne volonté de part et
d'autre on peut peut-être arriver à un
compromis juste fait une proposition
je garde ma p'tite laine mais je pique
un camélia de dans ton camélia qui
public et rouge pas
mark ii c'est toi qui décides de
l'emplacement m'assurer qu'ils veulent
une caricature de cérémonie et moi je
veux un mariage comme l'a alors chaque
article intitulé tu perfectionne sa
tenue par biais du tiw clochard avec
musique qui le rouge et camembert après
notre image ignol mariage bourgeois
c'est à dire c'est à dire que pour
commencer je sais de cohabiter avec toi
jusqu'au jour de la cérémonie
non mais tu oublies caisse d'internautes
et quand je vois le côté bien pensants
chaque année alors nous n'allons plus
vivre ensemble pendant huit jours en
bijoux ou plaisir moi ça valait le
pardon pardon pardon la date de notre
mariage et bien sûr c'est pour samedi
prochain
il adaptera vocale et autant qu'il le
faudra pour bien mettre des fiançailles
descente et un mariage des sens défiant
mérite mieux que ce que nous sommes
les concubins roland visiant je veux que
nous réfléchissions notre prochaine
niveau comme des fiancés dans la
méditation et la chasse aux filles
à ce que tu veut plus non plus je sais
que tu prends des risques calculés
parce que si j'allais voir d'autres
comme moi c'est que nous ne sommes pas
faits pour le mariage aux au nom même
nom mais décrit mois plus nos
fiançailles que je hurle de rire
alors on se reverra plus embarquez à
bord nova sont des soirées ensemble nous
livrons nous conte du cross clients
aillent aux élèves sont ainsi mis au
poisson ils peuvent bien rentré côté 6 à
sa fille si ce vaio niveau là mais moi
je te préviens en ce qui me concerne je
ne serais pas un point de franchir le
meilleur moyen d'accéder à la
spiritualité
on s'embrasse pour ceux qui bonne nuit
et chacun vous dans ces quatre dans un
état de frustration et aiguë très
nuisibles d'organismes normaux mirror
pour les avis qu'ils agacent les
appétits de nos métiers hier qu'il se
fasse d'ici qui tu m'as côté de dieu qui
nous tue actionnaires de puttaparthi
avec déjà guinée ils gagnent seulement
ces dîners cas maintenant imaginez
ah on sait comme a fait tu réalises je
serai pas le seul à être frustré au
monde qui fait je serais pas frustrer
vous quelques mois destino mon style pin
up séisme en défaut sur ce titre une
aube suis fier 3o alors fermé moi de te
rappeler un charmant souvenirs et donc
quand on s'est connus du partage son
studio avec une copine un jour la copine
d'importer du l'instant d'une laverie
automatique et dès qu'il a le dos tourné
qui c'est qui s'est jeté sur moi on va
absolument pas a profité comme si on
avait même calculé qu'on arrête pas
contre 5 minutes sans nous on avait
branché le minuteur de la cuisine parce
qu'on avait peur de perdre la notion du
temps aux cabines
oui et le minuteur il appartenait qui
fait qu'on a été pris en flagrant délire
martin copine a été très bien
elle a fait un essai à la détourner
pudiquement le regard alors qu'ils sont
pas que de larmes et en sortant elle a
dit bon bah je veux faire la passe de
plus
attends mais afin non non non non parce
que tu traites abandon mais tu m'as qui
serait une première fois qu'il ya eu
quelque chose entre nous est d'avoir
violé je respecte la vérité historique
est bien capable d'y échanger en cause
moi je n'ai remarqué aucun changement
non mais parce que c'est important de
gagner même si je peux me retrouver là
tu es si ce n'est pas parce que on se
quitte mon n'est pas ça chez nous non
la ville vient de lancer coûte en vente
au prix que ses statuts on vient de loin
je sois là haut avait que deux n'ont pas
offert quand même
or voilà comment pourrait-elle savoir
que ça n'aurait besoin la trouver pour
déguiser en touchant le moyen de prix la
plus dégradante siècle et zarafa ne
pouvions pas imaginer jeter dans les
poubelles
nous savions qu'ils pourraient alors
j'ai demandé l'asile politique à rots et
elle me l'a emporté c'est le
politiquement fin je n'ai pas une
réfugiée tu n'es pas une apatride
tu es ici chez toi pas légalement mais
que tu n'es plus heureuse avec moi et
bien moi je remercie le ciel tous les
jours du bonheur de vivre avec toi
si jamais entendu remettre cimetière la
prochaine fois attends moi pour comment
alors à partir d'aujourd'hui je remercie
le ciel pour les lire à haute voix
pendant deux heures bravo rafa marquez
non qu'est ce que je vais faire moi
qu'est-ce que je peux faire c'est
norbert oui c'est moi il vient en effet
soir par fait maintenant 18 euros
décembre s'il te plaît
norbert 50e fou raide dingue et si
redoutable
non pas question de rester neuf et de
rejeter toute la responsabilité sur le
dos des femmes à l'honneur mais
j'aimerais mieux en bas du col est de
comprendre sa douleur
enfin quoi il n'y a pas cinq minutes que
tu es marié ce que ta femme pour déjà
des fonctionnels c'est une chambre
d'anita paul watson oui c'est dans notre
statut de copropriété avoir une invité
les pinceaux et rhône alpes a demandé la
permission pour viviane une has in una
parce que tu crois que tu connais
viviane en grattant un peu qu'elle soit
installée se tient quelques questions
décibels elles comptent pour 12 m tu les
entends d'ici tout les deux trottinant à
longueur de journée leur salle de bain
d'attaquer bille august lui en craquant
tous voudraient avoir la peur et dans le
vide-ordures question d'organisation et
va bon courage
en tant qu'organisation je me suis
laissé dire que roselière et facilement
abri hélas dont oui je vais marcher à
tenerife 1 pour l on peut dire de
l'argent a dû s'en faire l'écho pin pad
et a même mis des copains par des mains
de cette façon on a du vent qui reste en
tête du peloton rang pourquoi se
paniquer mauvaise manie fort en voyant
en tout cas pas mieux de prendre une
position très ferme dès maintenant
écoute il faut que tu a réfléchi et que
tu ne veux pas recevoir hijab and on
n'avait pas prendre les allemands mais
avec tact et qu'elle comprenne bien que
quand tu dis nous c'est nous et donc on
se fond pour toi un respect qui pour
l'instant n'est pas évident c'est le
genre plutôt tendance à prendre pour un
bon ptit toutou d'appartements reibel
vous aviez avoir été l'occasion de ce
pas alors
attendez
avant de commencer le déménagement
j'aimerais que nous ayons une
conversation
[Musique]
tu as est superbe et gauthier il s'agit
que quelques jours selon jusqu'à samedi
prochain à midi voilà parce que tu
connais pas la nouvelle la date fatale
est retardé
regardez en octobre besset fantômes 3 -
oui et pendant tout ce temps là comment
tu le passes se creuser trois sic ou
plutôt ce que vous ne cite pas parlé du
maillot c'est une des tapisseries au
crochet ça te dit quelque chose
non pas ça dans les bus les camions
d'artisans la tapisserie awards alors
alors pour facile et c'est pourquoi j'ai
dû soumis comme une [ __ ] aurait pu
laisser embarquer à tenerife endroit
réputé pour sa jungle étouffante les
araignées géantes et ses mines a musclé
ses soyons juste que ce n'est pas sa
faute si j'ai été piqué par une tante
une tarentule et deux en bronze
quitte à piquer pour la vie si tu ne
réagis pas nos repères avant que ça
tienne incurable regarde moi c'est déjà
devenu un esclave
nous n'allons pas justement s'ils
pensent à la tapisserie au consulat pas
ça pense aussi que vos grosses déjà fort
initiale chez toi en faisant croire que
c'était pour huit jours alors que ça va
durer des mois des pièces quotidien sur
sa mère qu à petra de son père
et après ce rapide affamés de dreux qui
viendra fait bouffer dans sa phase de
barrage et que nous ne soyons réalistes
le cocu empêcher viviane vent très vite
y est déjà dans la place pour tous même
pas la planque hervé skalli avec les
vêtements en vrac ou t'es foutu mon
cheval entre et tout est foutu
qu'est-ce que je peux faire et rien que
rien fait pas s'y trouvent ne laisse pas
de revenir à leicester et je vois
quelque chose mais la suite reste à
prouver
qu'est ce que tu veux faire maintenant
que viviane est allé s'installer chez
toi now par grand chose
tu va promener c'est tout
invention bon alors
nous allons frapper un coup décisif
viviane va s'installer chez toi tu vient
s'installer chez moi avec toi ici en
bande ka travay creusot mon nom est
rouge a peur hein pour la cimade
montebourg et moi ce que je dis c'est
dans son intérêt c'est uniquement dans
son attaque lancée peut-être un peu
brutale après un mois de marianne c'est
son seul espoir
tu as raison je vais dire à rose que je
viens du pays tu es tu vas voir des
roses droit
à
j'ai quelque chose à dire oui ils
méritent tous les deux norbert de
l'écouter sans surtout s'il prétend
qu'il parle uniquement dans votre sac
erreur je parle de l'intérêt de tout le
monde si alors essaie de bouger de
parler à cg vous écoutez moi mon épouse
viviane voulait maintenant très
attention nathan sourire des mauvaises
ou non voilà toute une vie d'observation
m'a appris ceci vous prenez le meilleur
coupe du monde les têtes ou les plus
amoureux les allemands les plus
échevelés en plein centre s il peut leur
arriver de se chamailler gentiment et ça
n'a aucune importance
d'accord d'accord d'accord mais attend
de savoir où il dormira dans ce cas
d'accord a toujours un moment un couple
où le ton monte monte monte
après quoi il redescend et tous avancent
toujours d'accord d'accord d'accord j'en
ai dit tout s'arrange toujours si si le
couple est seul en tête à tête
maintenant pendant cet échange de mots
inoffensif introduisent un témoin
n'importe qui en a mis une belle mère un
télégraphiste et ces mêmes mots rendront
une tout autre résonance simplement
parce qu'ils seront prononcés devant un
tiers d'accord d'accord pas d'accord à
et pourquoi pas d'accord parce que j'ai
pas compris
nous voilà nous sommes seuls doigts et
moi alors une supposition que je te dise
comme ça dans un mouvement de colère
celle eric lejoyeux données
mais j'en sais rien quelque chose qui
n'a aucun sens ne sait pas par exemple
or bac 1 tu me rappelle mon adjudant qui
était pourtant une belle peau de vache
chose qu'aux services ares autres loups
tuent rien dit mais je suis mal vieilles
gloires non tandis que en prévente un
tiers d'un intime même se visionne les
mots aux deux vaches risque de provoquer
le drame c'est là qu'ils voulaient en
venir voilà les cobras ans maintenant et
c'est un peu d'hommes très vite coups de
masse avec vous sortez une graphie si tu
vas voir qui va t'arriver norbert aux
pauvres aux plongeons nous posons nous
la question qui argument est ce que la
présence de viviane chez nous découvrira
danger à notre union voilà l'essentiel
n'a fait aucune objection pour viviane
toutes leurs petites heures du matin
consulter tu m'as mis devant le fait
accompli
petit bézy l'aphasique c'était pour
trois mois par des étudiants deviennent
le prévenir
éric gagné ce n'est pas chez lui alors
écoute je me bats invité la fiancée de
tours meilleur ami sans consulter mois
se retourna drogue mais n'aurait je suis
ravi de recevoir design selon simplement
de me prévenir au cas où kim aurait
l'intention de continuer le recrutement
était bel et bien sous leurs bombes au
milieu de l'arène
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et pendant ce temps presse a déjà du mal
avec une belle et voilà voilà une chose
que nous n'aurions pas de montant des
loyers précise sa pensée on en parle on
prétendre à mieux
des monstres d'aller jusqu'au bout de 40
et ils vont devoir étudier sur le plan
racing mesure amène à croire une chose
pareille
n'est ce pas visia je n'ai pas eu
l'occasion de rendre coup par manon
barbe
c'est peut-être elle attend pointe
invitant chez elle que tu t'occupes de
son mari
[Rires]
on croise partout que tu vas bien aux
canaries indice das le climat éventuelle
action
c'est notre leader et je suis
convalescent non puisqu'on en parle
laissez-moi vous rassurer il ne peut
s'agir que d'une défaillance passagère
vrai moi j'ai entendu des confidentes à
deux demoiselles ont très très bien
connu norbert unanimité c'est un très
bon artisan la chose alors c'est moi qui
n'aspire pas même rendu dans ce produit
tout du tout du tout ce qui vous le dit
eric et d'entrée de tout leur ménage
aurait pour arranger des petites
affaires qui n'écoutant alors c'est si
peu moi non mais arrêtez cette
discussion si petit jerald brown là tout
est arrangé tu n'y as pas la scène il
est conseillé d'aller à l'hôtel pourquoi
il ya celle à laquelle s'ajoute à celles
annoncées par dj la lorraine et norbert
doit devenir chiant mais t'en fais pas
pour norbert il va très bien leur mère
n'est pas la peine levé bien ce qu'ils
veulent je ne vais pas dire que je ne
vaux pas évident d'y inviter l'artiste
et ses impasses comme papa et il vient
pas très bien dans ce cas aucun bilan
des lois en vigueur
la sortie du palais dans le quartier et
vous alliez ses seuls les deux en tête à
tête
on n'en serait pas arrivé là il faut
toujours écouter parce que j'ai toujours
reste d'envoyer bon alors juste pour une
nuit ou deux le temps que je trouve
quelque chose derrière
au nom des jeunes reste 3000 à 5000 à
vraiment faire au norbert autrement à 7
minutes précise l'histoire il offre un
virage capital nous assistons à
l'abolition de l'esclavagé de l'homme
tué un brave gloire à toi suis allé
regarder
oui très alors viens voir un coût énorme
défense traitait pas le moment de
fléchir
alors si et pour une fois je vais me
permettre de te servir moi même mais
n'en ont pas l'habitude et on espère que
je vais voir votre houleux mais non mais
non mais non il faut la prise est tout
de suite cette petite prétentieuse sinon
tu n'auras plus aucune autorité sur elle
ni super ni sur personne de ta famille
futur
enfin tu te rends compte qu'elle devait
te parler sur ce ton club de levante
d'enfants les enfants en les renvoyant
laveur autant pour les choses et parfois
malheureusement des fonds mais avait les
asservir à un coin du feu n'a dû
travailler ensemble d'ailleurs vous
accueillir le déménagement évoqué cette
affaire parce que je déménage parce
qu'il faut faire la belle devant kate a
constitué une j'ai une proposition à
frère d'un mariage moi je parle
sérieusement series et si on doit se
prononcer je déménage pas tout
aujourd'hui un tu pourrais revenir sera
détaillé au fur et à mesure j'ai pris
juste pour de joux
tout ça pour deux jours minimum oui
qu'on ne vienne pas me dire qu'il ya une
crise du textile aux attentes aux médias
qui avait tombé quelque chose l'arménie
eric besson ancien dramaturge il s'est
tourné c'est contraire à tous les
principes en europe ne nous mettre mon
dieu
pour une fois je ne t'ai jamais vu
pourtant ceux-ci order peut-on avoir dû
pourtant ainsi que jacques dalès
m'arracher mon psy c'est vraiment dieu
comme celle où instant là c'est le
voyage
je vais pouvoir vivre sans avoir peur
d'être dénudée a perdu joignent à nous
aiderait ce que je peux le garder en
souvenir d'un petit peu mais disons
c'est pas asseoir sa vie vient c'est
ensuite donne alors mika kallio pramac
souviens-toi les miens sont quand même
un peu plus discret meziane
qu'est ce qu'un slip tome qui n'est pas
à moi faisait danser après mais c'est un
homme effacé sa suite de norvège
affirmant y a que norbert pour porter
des trucs comme ça
ian puis je savoir pourquoi je garde un
site de norbert dans cette affaire
didier cuche ne rend pas compte mais tu
dois être en compétition
c'est ici c'est parce qu'il éprouve le
besoin inconscient de garder un slip de
norbert nantes et sa femme laureen
angers dire c'est pas norbert que tu
veux ce sont six titres normalement
manoeuvre japon n'est pas rose
le fétichisme n'est qu'une innocente
perversions sexuelles très mal terminée
pourri mais c'est pas mon campus
examinons c'est yann assurions viviane
si tu as d'autres dépravation gueule
avant de venir habiter chez nous et bien
oui d'un clic de lembeye ici chaque puck
à la mongie garçons aussi ce calvaire et
qu'il avoue ah oui oui gélules de ceux
tombés à et ça arrive tout à fait en
public chez les années
mais s'ils faisaient partie du premier
chargement voilà le second
mais pourquoi 10 heures du mans avant et
est restée pour expliquer le rap
hardcore
qu'est ce que tu attends bon voila comme
vous le voyez l'arrivée de lysiane c'est
vous produit des drames
alors si vous voulez dire pendant
quelques temps c'est parce qu'on a fait
les zones en bas les filles en eau comme
ça plus probable c'est norbert qualifié
d absolument pas non si votre mari vos
descentes offre ici c'est que je lui
accorder l'asile politique qui voulaient
demander
ben vous l'avez offert à viviane je vois
pas pourquoi j'aurais prévoient le faire
nos repères il voulait que son
surveillant puis c'est quoi qui en a
parlé le premier c'est venu comme ça la
conversation puis c'est tout norbert tu
viens vite et ici non alors j'ai pensé
voilà on va s'gêner là-haut adjoint
alors que c'est comme ça et là bas alors
star de l'avoir coup pour coup ben c'est
pas moi qui ai commencé le premier à
tulle quoi malherbe rendront les femmes
et les hommes en bas les diaries et
bientôt tu vas voir
et ben écoute norbert veux tu que je te
dise finalement tout ça c'est très bien
pensé oui il faut bien chercher le
restant de mes affaires avant que rose
des gones une arnaque
vous voyez ça je crois que tu es plus
court
ja
norbert appelle-moi intervalles
réguliers que je puisse orienter les
recherches
[Applaudissements]
mesdames
un nom mais lui que j'ai connu six en
plus haut c'est le mariage quand tu vois
je suis sûr que c'est le mariage non non
c'est ta mère qui était rousse bon alors
voulez vous m'expliquer en fois sa mère
qui était rousse et responsable avant
que je devienne fou mais les rouen la
peau très sensible jamais il est pas où
j'ai la même pose ma mère alors un
générique d qui s'est mis au soleil
révélait comme à gagnoa
voilà le mystère de la mer rouge
enfin éclairci mazicou minime que je
n'avais même plus le droit conscient de
ma chambre et il est resté au lit
et là il a été piqué par une belle note
une tarentule de la base nautique
stéphane sarrazin une baisse de la
taille d'un gros grard avec le corbeau
et le pasqua ne sais quoi alors
je suis sûr que c'est le mariage non non
c'est un maire qui était rouge bon alors
voulez vous m'expliquer en quoi sa mère
qui était rousse et responsable avant
que je devienne fou ménéroud en apôtre
incendiés jamais il est pas où j'ai la
même poubelle alors un pin eric d'équité
mis au soleil
désolé comme alone you alors voilà le
mystère de la mer trousses enfreint est
clair qu'aucune ligne contre avait même
plus le droit portion de la chambre et
il est resté au lit
et là il a été piqué par une belle une
tarentule de la part
[Musique]
voilà je suis rangé mes affaires je sais
pas vous dire ça qui vous réveille dans
les chalets pas qu'ils dormaient naoto
dans la chambre jusqu'à tous appellent à
north bay dis moi ce que tu as rangé des
affaires dans un des sites la carte
nvidia n'a laissé vide en ambroisienne
tu n'as rien mis dans mon tiroir mélange
alors retournée dans la chambre et que
je ne t'entends tu parles tu sais que
c'est dans les façons de passer un avis
d est pas un avis est un réfugié
politique quand est ce que j'aurai de
venir ici
l'argent est allé dormir
oh non non non 2 2 deux heures qu'il est
lasse des autres supporters ont pu
obtenir tenir jusqu'à ce que viviane
fait crocs
je ne sais que le travers une ola au
second set j'ai déjà demandé deux fois
là haut une seconde sous des prétextes
minable alors qu'est ce que tu vas
encore indiqué cette fois ci pour monter
là où une seconde j'ai cherché à lille
tu viens d'aller chercher un livre gérer
la lune n'est pas vrai tu peux pas
l'avoir ne diminue pas j'avais déjà lu
les romans suivants aperçu monthubert su
tout de suite
moi je vois alors tu montes sur sur un
livre que tu as déjà eu comme ça ça te
donne un prétexte pour monter sur ciani
ce que tu as déjà vu comme ça ça donne
un prétexte autres n ont en effet pas
fait exprès de vue avant de chercher ton
lit pas tout couvrir de ridicule baron
et aux pieds des filles
je croyais que tu l'avais des jeunes
je vais le redire une deuxième fois
d'affilée dormir se veut rester là où
israël
[Musique]
l'hydrogène tu fais toujours ce à quoi
la partie
je sais pas si tu t'en vas
ah non là là là tu viens de refaire
encore de quoi
j'aimerais beaucoup tu me laisse cuire
30 il mort et moi j'aimerais beaucoup
que d'une plateforme dans les dents
[Musique]
c'est parce que c'est une espèce de son
qui vient de la gauche
tu es la première personne qui m'empêche
pas les autres étaient sans doute trop
bien élevé pourtant paru il en aurait
parlé s'il l'avait remarqué ils en ont
vent par les mafias rien à remarquer
qu'ils sont ils des gens dont ils se
disaient les gens de toutes provenances
de toutes races de toutes couleurs là
mais tout sourd aux risques par hasard
tu lis réunis
oui 13 non admis en est patent je me
fais le vrai fait d'écouter jusqu'au
petit matin
[Musique]
une idée si tu dormait sur le canapé et
moi dans la chambre un nom je vais quand
même faire un essai
[Musique]
même couché même avec deux oreillers sur
l'a7 ce à travers surtout tout tu dis
quelque chose je prie pour qu'ils ne
continuent et continuent à lire donc
sans que je le pensais pas plus et vous
feront passer la nuit une tourterelle à
répétition olala choisir choisir vite
avant qu'on se couche pas qu'après ça
alors là c'est ça la plus grande carte
de magie moi je le sais depuis une heure
mais le new line
alors passé la goutte d'eau qui fait
déborder par tu sais que c'est toi qui
émet des sons inarticulés heureusement
ça je serai ceci vous écoutent nos
repères j'ai bien réfléchi
il est temps pour toi d'aller recueillir
les lauriers d'une à son héroïsme
qu'est ce que tu racontes a marqué le
coup t'as pas une position très forte
la finition est suffisante je suis sûr
que rose a très bien compris la leçon et
je monte là où la victoire trafford
alors écoute il faudrait savoir ce que
tu veux il ya deux êtres humains trouvés
par a plus b il fallait que je fasse
exactement le contraire de ce que tu me
conseille de faire maintenant alors là
moi sans avoir la tête sur un bon
terrain on écoute nos repères
sais tu combien de fois la barre changer
l'orientation de ses voiles quand il a
traversé l'atlantique en tête non au
moins une fois toutes les 20 minutes
alors un bon mari n'hésite pas à
manoeuvrer quand le vent tourne et
qu'est ce qui te fait croire que le vent
a tourné
la barre d'icônes lmr moi je connais les
filles je peux dire que la houle est en
train de changer il a déjà changé mais
qu'elles font en ce moment
elle pleure dans les bras l'une de
l'autre
[Musique]
alors d'après toi tu as fait du
personnel c'est pour ma connaissance des
sanglots à les surprendre
ils veulent avancer comme de grandes
glisses blessé une énorme et en voyant
tardieu après deux heures ils vont se
marrer et jazz où elle ne s'y attendent
pas c'est ça le coude mais tu montes là
où tu arrive enfin sur prend possession
du domicile conjugal et que j'aide
viviane d'or dans la foulée ah oui c'est
intéressant ton idée un témoin sauter
avec cela et vers paris nantes et
l'enfer nos frères la vraie raison qui
me fait de proposer de remonter les
toits comme un ciel un peu gênant
j'aurais j'aurais préféré ne pas en
parler dans ça comme tout de même ta
femme tu a accusé publiquement
d'impuissance qui a tiré la leçon
j'ai connu des moments difficiles et ce
soir comment te sens-tu moral est bon
aïe
mais le physique ça va alors qu'ils
n'ont cela aussi la venue tout de suite
à l'heure mais assure si elle donnerait
vie n'est pas parce que dans la vie au
milieu des casseroles sur les cas pas
que tu l'a déjà fait ah oui ça c'est je
dois dire que dans tempo marche aux
cammazes un média région ema humilié
devant tout le monde et patron monsieur
sait qu'une brute tentures ils ont su
comprend bien que viviane ne veut pas
assister à ce genre de spectacle c'est
pourquoi je te demande de me renvoyer
normal hein elle est bâtie maintenant
avec courage aller à l'assaut et bien
mais c'est pas ici qu'il faut le faire
savoir
non mais là je choses là que tu vas
faire plus pour l'énergie leur écriture
yavo essentielles permettent d'affirmer
pas pouvoir dépasser l'heure mais il a
perdu la tête un peu plus tonique rodi
oui je rentre à la maison
norbert tu ne peux pas en rester là
tu as raison maintenant c'est à elle de
faire le ménage n'est pas du tout
c'était toi et tu sais pourquoi parce
qu'elle est la faiblesse et que tu es la
force attend à ce que la théorie tu as
raison alors c'est comme si tu avais
tort réelles raisons reprend depuis le
début parce que giresse est pas très
convaincant dans les zones qu'il faut
être quelqu'un de très fort pour pouvoir
dire je te demande pardon j'ai eu tort
quand on arrive donc tuer cet homme fort
prend le téléphone et appelle rose sur
n'a pas à leur monde selon d'amitié et
trans tourner le long de la semaine par
les émeutes où diouf ne volerait pas
atteint des seuils n'aurait non non non
qu'est-ce que tu as comme ça dépend pour
quoi faire
quelle chance aura pour quoi que vous en
êtes des gens sont pas là où il ya les
participants légère associant joyeux
drilles si l'entretien à rhodia moi je
n'y arrive pas du côté gauche où est pas
facile on perçoit qui le roi du bouchon
n'aurait alors plus de m'ouvrir la porte
aux pour qu'il n'ya vraiment pas je vais
idée la couleur c'est fait pour essayer
la première fois deux heures suivi la
poubelle je suis un homme sonne
désormais en mauvaise voie et je ne veux
même plus loin j'ajoute que si tu
reviens vivre avec moi je continuerai à
vider la poubelle tous les soirs
dommage d'être obligé de renoncer à cela
mais à seulement sont que 30 se
réconcilier alors je l'espère de tout
mon coeur balance qui arrivent non bon
et bien sûr montrer d'ici jeudi dans 5
minutes norbert n'est pas redescendue
c'est qu'ils n'en sont déjà plus aux
bouchons de champagne
alors pendant qu'il se réconcilieront là
où on pourrait peut-être essayer de se
réconcilier en bas plutôt kravitz en
rédigeant voilà format de la partie je
prends le risque alors je m'écoute pas
réfléchis tu va les gêner
nico tu connais pas encore mais quand il
est déchaîné cette info non c'est quand
il est très capable de traîner le corps
contenant de rose à travers
l'appartement et de venir terminer
l'ouvragé jusque sur vos produits
mais qui connaît quand je fais mes mots
croisés rien de mise en å espère sans
doute que norbert aura besoin d'une
seconde victime
c'est normal il ya dix ans et qu'il a
d'après ce que nous savons
les possibilités sont rajoutés diminue
mais moi je te dis que j'ai un sixième
sens pour ce genre nouveau est que
norbert est encore avec rose comme un
frigo avec une gallo romaine de la bonne
époque
voilà
les wisigoths son fils qui faisait tant
de gens gagnaient les bouchers non il
succède selon ces études nous invite à
voir un bernard péré mois à un an ce
soit avec joie mais nous avons déjà du
monde des garçons évidemment si nos
savage habillé en pharand sableux rien
où le chanteur n'en fait pas partie
depuis deux heures tu as déjà réussi à
ramener des garçons qui étaient bénins
connaître ma chérie au secours je fais
porter avec deux américains maman à une
orgie petit les prendre sous son aile
façon vient viège répondu on au témoin
me semble en voie les comparer il y en a
aussi un nouveau pic pour ou de la tribu
des miss cameroun avait pas les plus mal
aimée skyros ils faisaient violer les
amenant parfois tu fais bien de prévenir
si j'entends une sonnette je saurai
steve pas redémarrer l'an passé les
saisons
camille intervalles réguliers c'est
l'impuissance
j'ai failli perdre et d'autre
il avait tout le temps que je serai bien
présent c'est aussi mine quand il lui a
consenti il est notre philosophie c'est
pourquoi pourquoi mais tu ne parviens
moi je ne vois pas de faire connaître
aidants cespa vous je n'ai pas faites
comme chez vous en ferez donc oui
norvège 11 tu n'a rien à faire ici tu
vois là où je ne peux pas trop bas
norvège
viviane et moi nous attendons deux
garçons bruxelles l'irréparable sera
peut-être consommé de cette nuit le sol
alors si tu veux mettre les américains à
la porte quand ils arriveront qu'il fait
des excuses et j'oublie bombe a redit
norbert celui des excuses soient nom
maintenant c'est moi je veux quelques
semaines à jouer qu'elle demande pardon
alors mettez vous un fondement de lui
par deux fois une fois bronze et à cambo
pas danger oui d'ailleurs je suis très
bien pourquoi il veut pas c'est parce
qu'il peut pas rose oui mais c'est cette
fois uniquement ma peau c'était en or
deux pénalités de sa part pour la vallée
pas épouser un manque de féminité sinon
nos repères
mais comment oses-tu part féminine aux
roses laissez-moi dû montrer mon
orientation des entorses de cirey mer au
côté madame si vous n'étiez pas sa femme
et sylvia n'était pas là mais qui pousse
avec je vous prendrai comme une bête
mois mais sous utilisés comme vous à la
pac dans le métro dans les magasins
partout et moi de me garder pour le
racing au prat minimes et elle promet
cela dit pour vous trois semaines
rypien plus la condition de ne pas
laisser se prolonger cette situation
malsaine au monde chez toi il y avait
tant promis ne repart devant moi que
couvert de lauriers à l'écouté eric
c'est un domaine qu'il connaît bien
tu viens aux rebelles en loge c'est
foutu devant au score
n'empêche c'est en fait n'a finalement
jamais fini mon sac rôle dans vos bras
mais si tu ne dois pas des détritus
times et kia avec caroline une vieille
connaissance avec elle je vous jure
qu'elle ait pas de problème avec elle on
va voir si c'est la faute de rose ou de
la vienne alors caroline cédant maire
norbert ceux des rentes avancer les
angles ouais je te rappelle dans une
heure alors on danse 10 heures salle de
bain se rappelle dans les gestes
c'est sa carte au hyatt
carole est là à webo jamais la grèce
vont car les spéciales demoiselle je
n'en ai ri en pêche
donc moi c'était un bon moyen pour lui
redonner le moral aux bonbons qui couche
avec sa femme avec le monstre du loch
ness et encore moins pour ceux qui ne
restent pas la technique va plus ça
dérange partie des 1001 livres dans wall
s'est brûlé vous parlez l'adresse la
veille de mon mariage il en rêvait j'en
ai besoin je pouvais leur cela thierry
alors norbert nous bleus on va prendre
une de ces fuites remarquèrent d'accord
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
alors aux eaux ou par étapes
pour sylviane au pardon c'est parce que
c'est à déshabiller devant d'arrosage et
il tombait sous la main ou pardon alors
c'était bien la fois réalistes les
américains seul louis dedans à doha tout
à fait inoffensif et pour tous du [ __ ]
comme des orchidées à bord et balourd
very quesnoy
on a près une vie dure de championnat
qui vient toujours envoyés pour la
journée sur les prix font tout à l'heure
maintenant ils sont en dur ou sous mac a
annoncé vous tu veux me réveiller un
hostile et gnangnan basque elle est
sortie pour aller face à elle à cet été
dans les bagages dimanche mais on y
quelle heure et il me dit je me demande
quelle n'est pas leur famille oh mon
dieu non pas ça drôle a le droit que sa
parole citoyenne a laissé un mot je vais
téléphoner à la famille annonce nos
repères en fonte et ce n'est pas du tout
sûr qu'elle soit allée à dreux c'est pas
la peine de les affoler inutilement et
zarour il va je suis sûr qu'elle va
vêler pas encore arrivé au japon ce
chiffon sans moto je vais tâcher
d'arrivée avant elle est là au pied
avant quel autre citoyen si vous avez
raison elle était partie premier bail
[Musique]
derrière la gare dit que quand on est
jeune mais tu vas me retrouver son fils
est grosse mais pas loin non c'est une
fin fois elles s'accroissent à norbert
cette petite vos petites rues de ses
mines et 1
c'est comme les orchidées du texte y
entendit parler des harkis ou à
l'instant même oui oui qui l'emmenait
n'ont jamais l'oreille collée à la fox
j'attendais l'occasion d'entrer
dignement je vais me lever et oui il ya
eu un début d'incendié
mais vous avez fait éliminer ce rôle en
voici vingt que ce soit on est plus
efficace travail ou pas selon la bcc
faut que je passe pour une fois alors
viens m'embrasser
non alors pourquoi bien que lorsque me
provoquer nus et au ctri ya deux ans
c'est une manille ap est d'avis que
j'aime bien ça me fait toujours le même
effet voilà c'était d'un coup là juste
derrière l'oreille m'ont dit on dirait
une morsure de baisse ce jeudi pourtant
c'est qu'il faut se méfier de rose 2
c'est un vampire
non le bonheur
wotan jamais dit qu'il fallait frapper
avant d'entrer dans une chambre à
coucher
non mais attendez c'est pas comme si
gameiro projet rouge n'aurait pas le
temps mais tu es fou tu vas à part les
adresses jeter dans la gueule du loup
écoute moi quiros lui en ai déjà parlé
dans mon père satan avec la carabine
adultes mais je prends le risque nous en
nos repères situe à l'ombre de bon sens
attends là ici rose va retenir enfants
alors va te coucher pendant mon idée
n'est pas nouvelle équipe manor b orthez
cet idiot ce que tu fais c'est une honte
nerfs lâchent
regarde moi les miens ont tenu et via
les vaincus ne bouge pas d'ici
rod à retenir en se traînant à quatre
pattes je t'assure que norbert haupert
non bon tout ça pas question de rentrer
chez moi avant six heures du soir au
moins et maintenant à nous deux tu vas
pas redescendre des affaires maintenant
nous avons autre chose à faire de plus
sur ces jeunes redescendre à la fin j'ai
d'enfants qui ne plaît ni 17 mai donc
pas même au premier par tu veux partir
tout de suite ou si murray semblait que
nous avions d'autres projets pour les
médias ou c'est ce qui me fait passer et
tu continues à trouver le bonheur
ailleurs
j'en sais rien mais ce que je sais c'est
que mon mari me 3 la paille clown ni un
amor mian égoïsme hisser n'ya rien
artiste un mari
si la faillite voilà à présent dans
l'arène bonne forme à marine ou tel cas
la solidité l'adoration existe non jeudi
maintenir la plupart des infos des maris
ses toiles exception alors imari et bien
jo depuis l'annoncé mari dans ma vie
comme capable de faire tout ce que je
fais depuis 115 ans pour le pack marié
n'est capable de tout pour tous pas ta
copine tu peux tu m'aimes mais tout ce
qu'il fait pour le concours viennent car
l'amour avec moi ça s'arrête là et donc
de deux ans une femme de vouloir autre
chose un bout de papier carton au dessus
des sceaux son idée a séduit récupéra on
trouve une partie bon alors dis-moi ce
que tu veux
et puis je te promets que je vais faire
un effort l enfant tu veux quoi c'était
le média l'idée je veux y avoir un
enfant ça va prend la fête
une petite pièce qui ont su un enfant ou
si besoin de calme de silence ne me
tuent 30 les hurlements du monde le dit
prend alors son compte et ou sting
havrais hyère coqueluche le bateau
l'engagement politique
mon fils mais tu veux me condamner à 20
ans d'affrontements avec m6 monstre à
condition que l'on fasse camélia ce
mauvais pas non non dix mois plus tôt
que tu as quelqu'un d'autre on vu un
petit pois au nahd ramon sa part des
messages simples d'accès danfoss d'avoir
features et couvé satan
eh ben tu vois même ça ça marche plus il
était temps qu'on sait maintenant ça
marche plus ça marche ça c'est ce qu'on
va voir
et tout de suite en quotidien
or le monde souffle et qu'est ce qui
vous arrive j'ai perdu mon souffle
je viens viens de me donner un grand
coup de coude dans le plexus pourquoi
parce que je voulais la violer c'est ce
que je lui ai dit parce que pardonnerai
jamais ça ne coûte que coûte dans le
processus est rigoureusement interdite
pendant que vous faites ici où je
cherche norbert une amitié voulons des
sorties y courent après vous à leurs
petits mais ils foncent sur drupal est
pas laissé partir vous préviens celui
d'une humeur de drogue combat vous êtes
toujours d'une image zag avec moi vendu
la preuve c'est que je vous offre du
café au niveau du café moi je veux bien
alors allez le faire vous-même ah bah
vous offre le café par la madone
il partit combien de temps et un quart
d'heure comme un fou mais oui mais
pourquoi vous êtes parti pour ne rien
dire à personne
résout la rentrée si mes parents j'ai
été jusqu'à la gare montparnasse et là
j'ai pas le courage de continuer à
l'idée d'affronter ma famille drôme papa
tout où j'aime quand on verse alors
l'âge et aux parents seront aux couleurs
aux mecs qui lui apprit les amoureux oui
et qu'est ce que vous seriez vous
innocent il me devient tout de suite vos
parents que norbert arrive sur les
chapeaux de roue mais je vais être
obligé de l'ardèche notamment une
dispute pas il me paraît difficile de
leur expliquer qu'il vient uniquement
quand on me l'a côtoyé vous avez à
l'essai en pyjama ça vous va bien
ah oui ah oui ces jolis coloris
mais
ça vient de chez dorothée desdémone ou
et viviane là-haut et prépare ses
bagages
elle revient vite il va vite et ailleurs
je vous prie de ne plus dormir arrive là
bas ça sort des communes vie des
citoyens mais pas en jeu dont vous avez
vous trouvé éliminant des sens parce que
il ya deux fois et puis surtout vous
allez faire votre numéro de téléphone
rien donc je voulais vraiment pas me
dire que je la vis or vous savez moi je
vous ai mieux sa robe des gens vous
donner ma bonne humeur ou alors ça a
l'air de réponse bien sûr sont pas
encore levés doivent être à la mince
trop haut vous je vois dans vous et vous
écarter à huy ah oui j'admire vraiment
aussi peu de temps vous avez semé la
panique tout fait mais ce n'était pas
moi mais les avants barcella que
commencer
non c'est vous qui avez tout pour le
caire on en vit également à chaque
rendez-vous qui l'avait rendue malade
dufour ont cette idée de mariage dans la
tête ne cherche pas gravement manqué ce
que ce soit si vous l'aviez chercher
alors peut-être c'est une idole à la
room au nouveau parfum s'annonce dans la
vie vous verrez qu'ils s'arrangent
toujours surtout à votre avis alors
c'est pas moi ressaisissez vous prenez
vos pays
après moi j'ai dit cramponnez vous mais
pas après mois à y aller
lady gaga s'est dit c'est moi
viviane attendre dix diables s'est
envoyé après moi oui parce que j'aurais
pu l'arrêter si vous n'aviez pas
enroulés autour de moi commencer à
l'horizon est aussi sûr que mardi avoir
obtenu ces connaissant la france ils n
ont rien changé à mes habitudes du
dimanche à moi aussi il me reste plus
qu'à temps de norbert je sais que ça
vous agace mais j'ai pas de brosse
d'aller l'attend tout seul là où je peux
rester là non j'ai pas envie de lire
jette un coup d'oeil sur les nouvelles
de la semaine et contingences
domestiques ont trop tendance à nous
faire oublier le reste du monde
norbert vous admire énormément ça fait
bien plaisir mais on va aussi j'ai
beaucoup d'estimé pour lui il m'a dit tu
sais pas s'il battait pour entrer si
vous avez viviane monospace a pas à
fonder leur tour dans l'entrée il m'a
dit que vous étiez probablement sans
rivale pour ce qui est lâché à
l'auditoire comme jules vie quand je
dois avouer que ma réputation s'est
passé comme il vous plaît dès lors dans
le domaine qui sera pas fâché même si la
france qui va se passer ici
non en fait il apprendra rien parce que
nous lui dirons rien tu me disais mais
qu'est ce que vous faites un quasi foot
et tri yann en gros un style par des
germes et remettez votre homme vous
n'avez pas lu ses choix en plus on nous
en sommes remettez votre homme
après avoir reconnu que les quais le roi
j'ai bien connu du tout bon il utilise
cette obligation d'en avancer aucune
obligation morale en tout petit face on
sait qu'en montrant un bon usage comme
the river à quoi que ce soit avec moi je
suis un sentimental argumentaire
comportement typique de voix blanche
elles n'ont pas appris alors ils font
comme celle de steur haute et habille on
y va et vient qui fut pas avec moi
remettez votre homme c'est pourquoi non
pas parce que j'ai déjà eu de mal à long
t on ce oui c'est pas facile vous savez
quand on n'a pas l'habitude de se
déshabiller devant à monsieur qu'au fond
on connaît pratiquement pas
pas heureusement vous vous êtes un brave
type mais non justement je suis pas
raciste alors habillez-vous aux usines
fabriquent après voudra plus rien
président non c'est donc au pour savoir
comment ça se passe avec un gros pari
d'un grand artiste mais norbert aussi
étroit et très doué il est très doué
norbert seulement ce moment est un peu
convalescent alors laissé huit sa chance
pourquoi est resté comme ça attendez
l'ex-star demande du temps mais attendre
quoi moi je veux savoir quoi les pas de
point de comparaison vous nous prenez
pour un étalon au bout je fais allusion
à lui dit cette mesure étant confirmée
on vous viendront rejoindre que la vie
vous a appris en vue d'une génération à
l'autre la transmission d'un certain
tour de main et finitions sacré magnum
de teint drôle de phénomène où ça
m'étonne pas que l'envers ce centre
avait dépassé par moments
évidemment c'est lui dans trois villes
voulez-vous me répéter ce que vous venez
de vivre
enfin si finalement ce sera lille
bénéficiaires obliginfos prix à la
hausse en volume vous me demandez de
rendre service à norbert au lieu
maintenant sa femme au point haut qu'est
ce qui va être content que je voulais
dire voilà tu peux apprendre d'elles
tomtom et la rose vous n'avez rien vous
allez bien puisqu'ils ne tend à rien
alors là vous me choquer mischer
profondément nous devons ce que votre
papa dirait si vous entendez obama c'est
bien ça se finit bien
mais d'abord je suis un homme marqué
vous êtes quoi aura rapidement marié
marié c'est justement ce que vous n'êtes
pas qui alors alors il veut justement ce
que vous ne voulez pas vous vivez sépare
évolution comme lié au gym
elle vous acquitter de célibataires
libre de rona il n'y a rien qui lui vaut
retenir sow d'apple
et j'ai senti l'odeur de votre
réputation à new york je vous remercie
infiniment de venu me dire ça ça fait
plaisir c'est comment vous remercie pour
votre petit fils qui espère conserver un
séjour voilà enfin mademoiselle en
madame au revoir merci paul mollahs
la route ou l'ont carrément finale de la
coupe de france de ping pong et ben si
je m'attendais à ça alors vous n'essayez
même pas en rose depuis ce que vous
voulez apprendre alors écoutez moi ne
suffit pas de se déshabiller il faut que
de sentiments un peu de un peu de
mystère
ah ben je sais pas me lancer dans l'art
cet instant mais comme tous les
débutants vous parler technique
or il n'ya pas de technique ma petite
fille il n'ya que notre direction que
vous mais qu'est-ce que vous êtes
congrès vous mais qu'est ce qu'on met
c'est pour de bon c'est comme ça un de
l'huile de l'huile pour rose et
hautboïste hautement vous voyez dans
secret oui c'est qu'il faut bien faire
pénétrer l'huile en outre le moral
éveiller la samba et non pas maintenant
apprendre aux enfants mais je ne peux
pas faire quelque chose que nous
regretterions tous les ans par la csu
nos prix norbert est mon ami non là
raymond aminé semaine un vrai risque
économique
donc il faudrait vraiment être le
dernier des [ __ ] seulement voilà je
suis le dernier des [ __ ]
c'est un contrat social où les rebelles
non ça peut être quelqu'un à l'autre et
norbert annuel en baisse de 8 h tripous
oui bah j'ai pas entendu pousser un peu
de friture là sur cet art aux alliances
on se croisait pas encore rentrée oui
mais où es tu toi au téléphone mais ça
n'avait remarqué mais où se trouve où se
trouve ce téléphone a ajouté il est à
houdan qui la terre varie sait pas
encore combien du stade rehausse y avait
ici mais c'est pas le moment d'y
renoncer le guide de l'île de france
j'ai besoin de savoir combien de temps
nous avons pour nous avance pas dire
qu'une poignée dire ici n'utilisent
jamais rien nous fait oublier les
réalités je fais les deux éléments
vouloir en plus écoutée même si vous
voulez un professionnel oui ou non
alors sachez qu'un professionnel ne
laisse jamais rien au hasard ou de
recoins 63 km au total
norbert à une très grosse moto où la
vitesse est limitée à 90 à l'heure il
respecte les limitations dont qui ne
dépassera pas les 140
nous avons donc à peu près 24 minutes
devant n'ont plus produit de remise en
état avant la gamme norbert voilà la
vraie nature est récente mais le temps
perdu en prétentions avant permet
révisez bien si ceux ci après c'est ce
que je vous dis attendez ce n'est pas
fini je viens pas quelque chose de très
important c'est un conflit un coût qui
vient terrain il ya un petit
inconvénient c'est que après moi je dors
je croyais qu bavardaient tendrement sur
une cigarette il y en a mais moi je dis
qu'est ce que je vais faire dans 120 cas
l'esprit bas du dos
nos camions bien dormir depuis
d'admiration durement 127,6 dormira
aussi c'est agréable en tout temps c'est
bien mais ce réveil fait du bruit en
moins sérieux tranche est pas moi j'aime
pas tellement cette technique du réveil
j'ai l'impression d'être un rôti de veau
c'est très beau ce que tu viens de dire
n'ajoute plus rien maintenant hein tu te
fais est une autre
o dans la salle aux ordures
pour rich deux en deux ans sans tromper
vidal pour en arriver là faux jeton
obsédé oui un cd bon maintenant que j'ai
fait mon autocritique ne pensons plus
qu'au bon côté des choses
bien évidemment rien
non non non non bien sûr la compagnie
tice à eva parce que c'est une insulte
une manière de dire bonjour il ya dix
jours yahoo se dit bonjour bonjour ma
petite photographie d'ilan halimi
j'attends c'est pas ton problème tu
prennes iard vainqueur en disant qu'ils
savaient bien que j'allais revenir à ben
nous l'a souvent des traces du tout du
tout du tout changement commence raide
hésité à des fois pour des raisons de
tihange lundi à hanoï où l'on veut très
en forme
alors bon c'est pas comme ça voilà face
à des forêts onf et comment j'ai pas
aimé bien
randall câblés
mais qu'est ce que susan jeunesse
houphouëtiste coup d'envoi du compte
qu'est ce que ça dit la tunisie est ce
que tu as quand à wii une fois parti
tagammu traité au cinéma métropole à la
brasserie la coupole a fait un cinéma la
coupole
connais tu prends la rue d'alésia voilà
l'été puisque le projet de fusion
jusqu'au bout c'est jusqu'au bout et
puis avant arriver à la place géraldine
se sont honnêtement oui alors ça me voir
et qui trouvera très envie de me décrire
le snphar ça tu sais moi dans ces
situations là je suis pas tellement et
pas tellement l'homme des grands
discours toi qui préfèrent avis c'est
oui je préfére à la résistance et à la
soumission à nos ados ah non surtout pas
à nous n'est pas question de nous trois
mois d'abstinence
c'est toi qui avait raison il n'ya
redire de peine arrivé qu'une brèche âme
il faut tony les photos dit on sera
maintenant j'ai dit aux familles et à
vos régions du maule montre la regardent
ils ont encore dû renoncer l'espace de
dignité humaine
mais car demain oui ça sentait malgré
tout ce que tu dis est malgré tout reste
encore à apprendre la langue galloise
alors après on part des femmes est pas
moins de serre mais rachel italien dès
que j'ai mangé mon studio leur écoute
pas de son émission
car tout ce qu'il faut ici alors viens
moi d'abord dû manger ici commence à
chercher sur lequel apple n'est pas
tellement
alors bien sûr police n'ont pas mort on
l'y voit seulement police mais c'est la
première fois plus rapide à léonie là ce
qui vient mais quelqu'un dans la cendre
était folle en font les dimanches tu
sais bien que madame martin devient
quand semaine à maurice à des courses
répandu soumet quoi mais une cd ou quoi
enfin avec les chiens qui peut viviane
pourquoi des trucs qui est qu'elle tient
dans la chambre comment aurais-je pu en
si peu de temps
découvrir choisir réduire et conduire
ici une femme pendant son absence en
france assure que même moi pourtant
réputé sans rival dans ce genre de
spécialité tu serais pas sur deux ans
vers paris en a pas toujours été ainsi
non maintenant lanone universalité ce
n'est pas maintenant mais personne n'est
pressé
forcément tu veux me servir à autre
chose a dit hannon un euro c'est vrai
que j'en étais pas j'ai eu la force de
sortir les novices supplée lydiane
écoute moi nous n'avons rien fait de mal
mais vous avez mm c'est par une chose
mais attention boyard ah non l'intention
de coop à l'acte c'est moins bon moment
de rire nos racines maintenant pas vivre
avec toi moi t'expliquer je t'assure
qu'il faut nous comprendre nous étions
tellement désemparé tous les deux noms
cités oui il m'a dit pascal atteint 10
premiers mais il s'agit pas prêt non
plus ah bon alors de qui s'agit-il
suivent à trouver de sa difficile à
croire quelqu'un qui se connaissent très
bien sales usa vient la dernière
personne à laquelle tu penserais je vois
oui oui je l'aurais voulu
[Applaudissements]
robert joly famille n'était pas content
mais je n'ai pas confiance en vous et
rien pour sauver l'honneur à m le
résultat que jamais au 13 c'est
incroyable elle croit qu'il s'agit de
nous de nous de commencer le deuil de
toi et moi le toit et moi j'ai en face
de nous deux et tu sais pourquoi elle
s'est mis dans la tête que nous étions
devenus de folles tout ça à cause de
voir parce que tu es sorti d'un long
bras qui n'avait absolument rien après
comment t'as rien à perdre a visé depuis
hier où il obtient ses jolies ou dans
l'intérieur j'étais pas sale menteur pas
des fois on est ce que moi google années
de vie ce qui s'est passé ce qui s'est
passé ne s'est pas construit nature avec
une fille
elle n'est pas là elle n'est pas là
réside non mais comment tu fais est elle
comme d'habitude l'agrément merci mon
dieu tu es un frère un seul juré oui
d'accord j'aurais bien du juge et
d'entretien alors voilà norbert ce biais
je n'ai pas eu le temps de faire quoi
que ce soit avec par femme
j'en ai eu la france et mais je n'en
n'ai pas eu le temps se tuerait quant à
la cause est entendue ça mais par contre
j'ai eu le temps d'apercevoir à quel
titre amoureuse elle elle appartenait et
alors avec elle
avec rod rencontrait en sol la passion
depuis que je connais tu m'a toujours
dit elle sans doute pareil elle n'aime
que les cosaques pas rose à arosa loire
et qu'elle soit maintenant une fleur
unaf 1 défiera les motards pouvait et tu
me tenir au courant les valides
alors à bien regarder partout torbey des
tea parties chercheront j'ai changé
d'avis en rose d'ailleurs de dire
qu'elle est revenue pendant te regarder
sous les noms qui ont fait venir nous
demander des fautes à présent alors pas
salle comble voilà une femme qui part
pour la vie quelques dix minutes afin
qu'ils se permet de poser les questions
et qui en plus nous accuse mon meilleur
ami et moi
même d'être devenu de folles tordues
comme il part donc du temps bah oui ça
pardonne de pampelonne votre pardon pour
tous mais mon dieu mais que je suis avec
toi vous pardon avoue ainsi norvège
bonjour tout le monde peut se fonder
légal alors maintenant logement des
services haut de gamme à billets parce
que 1 m 100 m
qu'est ce qui vous fait dire à cette
chance
ainsi seulement ses propres qu'est ce
qu'elle faisait là les bouteilles enfin
c'est pas allons voir une rose 9
septembre carreau alors non non non non
je suis formellement nommer ici sur les
villes au panama ah oui oui et ses
devoirs
oui elle est à rose je la reconnais mes
filles de covivo son papa éric mois
pourtant ce moment vous donne envie de
tuer au dos puis je le connais j'ai
envie de tuer seulement la solidarité
masculine avant tout l'espace je ne
comprends pas si vous voulez dire
alors qu'ils avaient trop d'ailleurs in
time chaque mois écrit hier soir voilà
pourquoi on était tellement saoul à
mettre des limites et alain wahba
corinne a reculé de 4 personnes
parfaitement lucide norber y est j'ai
trouvé ses pendants des ménages dans
l'ain voilà on est mélangé
souvenez vous de mon supplice faire que
ça fait non verts avouez que vous êtes
monté chercher ses 30 passes que vous
aimez vous aviez en forme
bah oui j'avoue que ça me détend à mesa
l'aventuré
voilà tout est expliqué alors vous
voulez finir votre petit somme très
vives en pratique dans la ville estime
oui ah oui oui j'aime bien mâchonner un
brin glycines en dormant
vous vous êtes douter quelque chose
alors vous êtes monté paradis qui risque
fort moi je vais vous l'avez pas
eric des territoires seulement venir les
trous d'errance et sans remplaçants sont
rares
sans rien voulu dire sans rien
pouvais-tu à dreux mais qu'est ce que tu
vas dire à tes parents tu m'as tu
affectionnes ou de septembre est ce que
tu vas faire et une valeur bien pourquoi
on s'alarme à pardies mal en plus non
plus long
j'espère que personne ne vous avions
demandé tout nu dans la glycine non elle
est très fluide
les parents vont en faire une maladie ou
une pizza etc afin de mettre au monde si
vous allez beaucoup de pc quand vous des
techniques tout le poids alors peut-être
la peine d'essayer
nous invitons boskin l image c'est pour
toi ma chérie je t'invite à déjeuner au
sort et aveuglante il ya quelque chose à
vous reprocher l'intention mais par la
mesure
witi aux jurés une déclinaison pas tout
ça nous a pris comme ça que c'était un
coup de sang qui nous a dit pas ce que
vous faisiez et que vous vous êtes
retrouvé dans les bras des jo sans
comprendre ce qui vous arrive est je le
jure je le jure aucune phrase de
préméditation
vous êtes deux hommes en seraient les
fnac c'est on parle de massacre et tu
lances à eau
norbert merci de quoi mettre arrivée par
la glycine tu m'as tu aurais je suis là
pour ça trop de les faire une grosse
bêtise
merrick tellement calme et norbert crois
quand même que tu devrais lui demander
de 12,3 ou non et s'imaginer ce qui m'a
dit qu une arme savez km et puis quoi le
troisième un tuyau traviata tuyaux mais
voilà la rose et voilà aucune
préméditation eu une vision nous quand
nous serons mariani
sa vie va vite je viens de dire quand
nous serons mariés
je ne rêve plus aucune raison de céder à
la tentation qui n'est pas admis non ce
que je veux quand même d'avoir envie de
régulariser c'est le mot c'est le mot
bon alors qu'est ce qu'on fait on va au
restaurant on régularise au restaurant
il sert jusqu'à 3 et jusqu'à trois
hommes alors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les messieurs la pièce que nous avons
jointe pour vous ce soir est de joy et
ben on a adapté par jean marchand
le décor et de rosé art
les costumes de donald cardwell
avec daniel prévost
tony marshall
[Musique]
daniel vol
la virée entre elles mais de michel roux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
non
[Musique]
là